here's this guy right here who's been
obviously drinking marijuana
[Laughter]
culture corner shin nick hayden fellas
down here in uh melbourne australia
we've been locked down for
quite a while now stage four we can't do
[ __ ]
we can't go more than five kilometers
away from our house
how many stages is this my brother's
obviously that means why is the lip
i haven't had a saucer in about six
months and i just wanted to know
dudes with ponytails king of stain
gang gang buzz cuts he looks like
everybody from this podcast
i think you know how hard it is to grow
up in another country i say it looks
like my brother is a handsome dude
he is a subtle hell he has a setup
easy on brothers your brother has a
grateful dead tattoo on his chest
easy easy easy
grateful bread over there
dude this guy uh set a lips on him
but also you know cat
said this man she doesn't dig guys with
long hair
yeah um long to a certain extent like
the
late 90s like kind of shaggy longer here
on dudes is fine if it's longer than
mine i'm kind of like hmm if you're not
jason mamoa i'm not
here see i i'd like mine get long enough
put in a man bun that should be dope i'm
getting there i'm close
you were close and then you got it cut
for some weird reason i freaked out dude
yeah that's why yeah you're right cap
broke the news on uh our new cats after
dark that she's single
we lost all our patreon subscribers or
you're not single anymore
no i'm still single oh okay you're
dating someone yeah but that's not
different from
fair enough fair enough
your date zone on the regular cat yeah
what
yeah who is this lucky gentleman huh uh
and why are me and theo pissed
nick was fist too i don't know nick was
upset yeah nick he was like what the
[ __ ]
who is this young gentleman look at a
good nickel said he had to go check the
equipment
i looked over there because like this
she's like so [ __ ] up guys
the [ __ ] cameras are off hold on cat
talks quiet
[ __ ] oh what happened guys i met him
through mutual friends that's it
wow white guy this is first of all i
want to say this is the
shittiest episode of a family feud i've
ever watched
good answer
they should have family feud in his
ph.a.m and it's just oh
that could be so good the weirdest
vietnamese game show
yeah that's hilarious i got no guesses
it's vietnamese people and white people
just trying to
kind of figure out each other out yeah
chin do you know
yes he does
[Laughter]
tight move nick
the timing was perfect chin freaking
nose dude you
[ __ ] in the dark weirdo
yeah dude the only thing that [ __ ] in
the dark are [ __ ]
dolphins dude you're out of your mind
man
[Laughter]
unbelievable unreal
[Music]
is